the media turned the new zealand white
supremacist terrorist attack into a
referendum on president trump
kirsten gillibrand experiences
predictable failure to launch and
president trump goes wild on twitter i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
oh man lot of news to get to today beta
o'rourke blowing it out in the
fundraising on his very first day we'll
get to that plus
more good news for beta o'rourke
apparently all data from myspace
2003 to 2015 has disappeared so
apparently beto's hacker friends got to
it
i see no other explanation we'll get to
all the news in just one second first
let's talk about an unfortunate fact we
are all going to plots i know we just
had a nice weekend you don't want to
think about that but here is the reality
if you don't think about it
if you're not an adult then you are
going to be caught up short if god
forbid something happens to you more
importantly
your family will be getting life
insurance can be kind of difficult this
is why you need to talk to my friends
over at policy genius
policy genius is the easy way to get
life insurance in just two minutes
you can compare quotes from top insurers
and find the best policy for you
when you apply online the advisors at
policy genius will handle all the red
tape for you they will even negotiate
your rate with the insurance company
no commission sales agents no hidden
fees just helpful advice and
personalized service
policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy they also make it easy to
find the right home insurance
the right auto insurance the right
disability insurance they're your one
stop shop
for financial protection so if you find
life insurance puzzling head on over to
policygenius.com
in two minutes you can compare quotes
find the right policy save up to 40
to doing it policy genius is the easy
way to compare and buy life insurance
once again that is policygenius.com be
responsible go get some life insurance
right now you can take care of it just
pause the podcast and take care of it
right now policygenius.com
policy genius the easy way to compare
and buy life insurance all right so
last thursday night obviously western
west coast time there was this horrible
evil terrorist attack in
new zealand a white supremacist goes to
two mosques and
shoots and kills now 50 people the death
toll has been raised
to 50 and the entire west mourns because
this is an act of evil
and this as i said last week should be a
moment of unity because when there are
tremendous acts of
evil then we should at least grant the
credibility that the vast majority of
human beings
in the west are saddened by an act of
evil
and are not sympathetic to the killer
how many people did you see who are
sympathetic
to the evil white supremacist white
supremacist murderer
on friday did you see any there really
pretty much nobody pretty much nobody
yet the media decided that this was an
opportune moment to push a political
narrative
and this is one of the worst aspects
about our polarized politics that is
whenever
there is a flash point whenever there's
an incident the media immediately jumped
to
which narrative does it back and can we
support that narrative
with other pieces of evidence or
non-evidence can we draw a narrative
from a flashpoint so
in ferguson missouri where a white
police officer shoots a black guy
they immediately draw a narrative white
police officers across america are
racist the criminal justice system is
racist
in the united states when there is a
shooting on a congressional baseball
field however and bernie
sanders is the person whose name is in
the killer's mouth
then it's not about bernie sanders it's
not about bernie sanders
large-scale radical rhetoric nothing of
that comes up
because that doesn't back the narrative
okay so what are the narratives that the
media wishes to draw from new zealand we
talked a little bit about this on friday
because it was pretty obvious
that the media were attempting to draw a
narrative their original narrative was
going to be
about gun control then they realized
that new zealand actually is relatively
gun controlled and it's a bad
it's a bad example if you're gonna
choose a country that requires gun
control new zealand is probably not that
country
they have 1.2 million guns and 35
murders a year in the entire country of
new zealand
so it is not a perfect example of a
country that desperately needs gun
control
nonetheless the country will look at gun
control so that took the narrative off
the table
the secondary narrative was going to be
a narrative about islamophobia the idea
that all across the west there are
people who deeply hate muslims
and because there are people who deeply
hate muslims all across the west
they led this white supremacist to go
around shooting people now what the left
labels as deep hate of muslims
is anyone who points out that radical
islam not
islam itself radical islam is a problem
or points out that radical islam is not
just a
tiny fringe phenomenon inside the muslim
community that if you look at the global
muslim community if you look at places
like afghanistan or places like iraq or
places like iran or places like egypt or
places like saudi arabia or places like
qatar or places like the uae or places
like jordan or places like oman or
places like yemen if you look at any of
those places
what you will see is that radical
islamism is not actually a fringe
phenomenon alone
and if you look at pew global research
polls of how people believe
what you see is that a large number of
people in a lot of these countries
pakistan
afghanistan 99 of people in a in a
pool of afghanis from 2010 pew research
poll
thought that honor killing was okay okay
that is extreme
by any definition that is extreme now if
you point that out the idea is that
pointing that out
led to what happened in christchurch
that is an absolute slander and it is an
absolute lie
and it is disgusting it is disgusting
now it's very funny
because the same exact people who five
minutes ago were suggesting that you are
not allowed to use anti-semitic language
the way that ilhan omar
uses it but people who point that out
the people who point out that el hanomar
uses anti-semitic language
are actually trying to shut down the
debate over america's foreign policy
with regard to israel
are today trying to shut down any sort
of talk
about radical islam generally now today
isn't necessarily the day to talk about
radical islam although
radical islam had itself a weekend there
was a terrorist attack in israel there's
now a terrorist attack going on
in the netherlands both of them have
been linked to radical islam at this
point
but it is true that in the wake of the
murder of muslims that is not the time
to talk about radical islam
but that's true on every side that's
true on every side meaning that if you
are somebody
who wants to question whether radical
islam is a dangerous phenomenon
across the world tying that to a white
supremacist murdering
a bunch of innocent muslims at a mosque
in christchurch
is a pretty vile tactic and yet that is
what you saw across
the media that is what you saw across
the media i'm going to start with some
students confronting chelsea clinton so
chelsea clinton
made the mistake this terrible terrible
mistake what was her terrible mistake
chelsea clinton said that ilhan omar had
been anti-semitic ilhan amar
is the muslim congresswoman from
minnesota
who is in anti-semite she has three
times in the last two months
humiliated herself with open
anti-semitism and the last time
she did it so obviously and so clearly
that the democratic party was on the
verge of condemning her and then the
radicals in the democratic party stood
up and they said no no no no we're not
going to do that we're not going to
condemn her
we'll take her name out of the
resolution and then we'll turn it into a
resolution condemning every bad thing on
planet earth
including islamophobia so chelsea
clinton was one of the people who called
out ilhan omar
for using anti-semitic language well
students confronted chelsea clinton and
they are blaming chelsea clinton
these students they are blaming chelsea
clinton for the shooting in christchurch
this is how radical the radical fringe
of the left is chelsea clinton is
somehow to blame for a white supremacist
shooting up a church in christchurch
because she called out anti-semitism
from ilhan omar
this went viral over the weekend
students confronting chelsea clinton
after all that you have done all this
homophobia
this right here is the result of a
massacre
stoked by people like you and the words
that you will put out things before
and i want you to know that and i want
you to feel that deep inside the 49
people died because of the rhetoric
you put out there
you can hear people snapping in the
background what does i'm sorry you feel
that we mean
what does that mean what is she supposed
to apologize for she's supposed to
apologize because she called out ilhan
omar for being anti-semitic
so if you call out a muslim for being
anti-semitic then you are responsible
for the murder of other unrelated
muslims who are not being anti-semitic
in christ church okay and then these two
people the people who are who are going
after chelsea clinton for goodness sake
i mean how radical is the left they're
making me defend chelsea clinton now
okay this is unbelievable these two
people were given a platform in buzzfeed
news
a platform to explain why they called
out chelsea clinton for the shooting in
christchurch
buzzfeed news posted a a piece by these
two radicals whose names are lin tweek
and rose ossoff
and it says why we confronted chelsea
clinton at the christchurch vigil
here's why yesterday we posted a video
of leon
confronting chelsea clinton at a vigil
for the victims of the white supremacist
new zealand mosque massacre
today we woke up with over a hundred
thousand people talking about it on
twitter needless to say this is not what
we expected well it sort of was
we went to the vigil for one reason to
grieve the loss of innocent lives that
were stolen from this world by vile
hatred we wanted to join our friends and
colleagues in a time of heartbreak and
agony to remember the 49 muslims who
were murdered for being muslim we did a
double take when we first noticed
chelsea clinton was at the vigil
just weeks before this tragedy we bore
witness to a bigoted anti-muslim mob
coming after representative ilhanomar
for speaking the truth
about the massive influence of the
israel lobby in this country
we believe ilhan omar did nothing wrong
except challenged the status quo but the
way many people chose to criticize omar
made her vulnerable to anti-muslim
hatred and death threats we were shocked
when clinton arrived at the vigil given
that she had not yet apologized to
representative omar for the public
vilification
against her so ilhan omar was a
wounded innocent in all this chelsea
clinton was the offender and because
chelsea clinton called out ilhan omar
for being an anti-semite this supposedly
led a white supremacist
to murder people in halfway around the
world in new zealand
many have said it was unfair to connect
chelsea's words to the massacre in
christchurch these two
adults right to them we say that
anti-muslim bigotry must be addressed
wherever it exists that includes chelsea
clinton
okay a couple of quick notes a couple of
quick notes
about the two people who were just given
space in buzzfeed
to harass chelsea clinton some more okay
it turns out
that these that both of these people are
deeply
radical in every possible way and they
got their defenders of course from the
radical
left and and their friends the folks
over at the intercept and such
so a couple of things dweek tweeted out
quote you're only interested in
demolishing israel not in finding a
solution
uh demolishing israel is a solution so
the same people who are calling out
chelsea clinton
for supposedly being anti-islam for
calling out ilhan omar
are themselves deeply anti-semitic to
the point where they are calling for the
full demolition of israel
the full demolition of israel it's
unbelievable okay and the other woman
who wrote this
repeatedly used the term the f
word for for gay people
in the united states but those people
were given a platform by buzzfeed news
it's just wonderful and this sort of
dishonesty was endemic in the media
endemic calendar star swords did the
same thing linda
saw a radical anti-semite and by the way
friend to terrorists
right legitimately has has stood with
terrorist rasmus
on stage and hugged her and all the rest
linda sarsour tweeted out i am triggered
by those who piled on representative
ilhanamar and incited a hate mob against
her until she got assassination threats
now giving condolences to our community
what we need you to do is reflect on how
you contribute to islamophobia and stop
doing that so
you see how this works the idea now is
that if you criticize dilhan omar for
being an anti-semite
somehow you're responsible for the
massacre in christchurch
that is the most extreme wing of this of
this push but that is not the
that is not the leading edge of the push
that is not the mainstream of the push
the mainstream of the push
is that anybody who has criticized
radical islam in any way is somehow
responsible
for what happened in christchurch i'll
get to that in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that our
federal government is simply out of
control
out of control on every possible level
congress is filled with crazy people
it's a nightmare and people are tired of
complaining about it and that's why i'm
a big believer in calling a convention
of states where we the people can
propose
amendments yes amendments that could
force congress to stay within its
boundaries could force the executive
branch to stay within its boundaries the
fact is that the founding bargain
that there will be checks and balances
between the various branches that
founding bargain has been eroded
over the course of centuries and it is
time to restore
that founding balance that the
legislative can check the executive the
executive can check
check the judiciary and all the way
around that's why we need a convention
of states
it's the only way to get a job done
there are already 3.8 million people
with us on this more every day so join
me and my friend mark meckler go to
conventionofstate.com
ben and sign the petition today that is
conventionofstates.com
ben a lot of folks talk about how
exactly this would work
it is a fully constitutional provision
under article 5 of the constitution
it was designed to work this way it
hasn't been taken advantage of but now
is the time
for us to stand together and restore
some of those constitutional balances
and checks
conventionofstates.com to sign the
petition today conventionofstates.com so
as i say
the most radical wing of the of the left
is suggesting that people like chelsea
clinton are responsible for christ
church the mainstream of left
is suggesting that people like sam
harris and i are responsible for
christ's church
and so there's a piece over at the new
york times in which a guy named omer
aziz
writes a piece called our brother our
executioner and he suggests
that anybody who criticizes islam as
having an internal problem is
responsible
for the situation in christchurch he
says islamophobia is not a fringe
problem
it is embedded in much of western
society for over two decades now the
entire the span of an entire generation
the whole muslim community has been
forced to accept collective guilt and
punishment for every act of terror or
violence committed by one of its members
never would or should this standard be
applied to white people who seem to have
kept the privilege of individual
differentiation for themselves
i don't know where he's getting this
this is a lie muslims are safer in the
west than they are in the muslim world
and the fact is that in 2017 in 2017
islamic extremism caused 84
000 deaths worldwide 84 000 deaths
nearly all of them were not in the west
that's according to cbs news a new
report
from the council on foreign relations
the global extremist monitor produced by
tony blair's institute for global change
okay the fact is that muslims in the
west are not only overwhelmingly treated
well
just as jews in the west are
overwhelmingly treated well even if
there are anti-semitic attacks
from white supremacists on occasion this
notion that widespread islamophobia is
dominant in the west because there are
people like sam harris who ask about the
nature of islam or bill maher who asked
about the nature
of radical islam or people like me who
point out that polling data show
that radical islam is not a tiny tiny
tiny phenomenon
that attempt to expand the argument is
really in bad faith and not only in bad
faith
counterproductive because the fact is
that if we refuse to call out radical
islam
then radical islam does grow in the same
way that if you refuse to call out white
supremacy white supremacism grows
you have to call it out it's important
to call out this stuff
that's what provides protection for
actual non-radical muslims
and at the same time you can call out an
ideology and also say that innocent
people should not be killed under any
circumstances
it's astonishing that folks in the media
refuse to acknowledge this fact
in a second i'm going to show you how
the media are are contributing to this
narrative
so for example going back to ilhan amar
for a second
ilhan omar is radical on israel she's
not just radical on israel she's an
anti-semite she's an anti-semite and the
push from the left is that if you
criticized ilhan omar this meant
that you were actually anti-islam that a
criticism of ilhan omar
made you an islamophobe now again this
is hilarious because the same people
who defended ilhan amar will say that
being openly anti-semitic does not make
you anti-semitic but certainly if you're
anti-israel that is not anti-semitism
or if you say anti-israel things that
doesn't make you anti-semitic that's a
proposition with which i generally agree
but those same people will say that if
you criticize ilhan omar then you are
anti-islam
the washington post just gave a full
op-ed space to ilhan omar
to talk about her foreign policy i don't
remember them doing the same thing to
steve king
i don't remember that at all and yet
that is something the washington post is
pushing because the generalized
narrative the media wish to draw is that
what happened in new zealand is the
predictable result
of islamophobia in the west the same
folks will say that
the radical islamic terror attacks are
not the predictable result of the growth
of radical islamist ideology but they
will suggest that radical
white supremacist terrorist attacks are
the growth of white supremacist ideology
in the west
now here is my view the growth of
radical ideology has consequences no
matter
which ideology we are talking about i've
worried about the growth of white
supremacism
for years i've been talking about it
openly since 2015 2016. it's been four
years i've been talking openly
about the growth of white supremacy and
white supremacism online
i'm glad that some people are finally
arriving to the party but the fact is
that the media narrative here is not
truly directed
at stopping white supremacism it's
directed at two things
linking president trump and the right
generally with white supremacism
and linking anybody who has critiques of
radical islam
with violence against muslims and that
is not only inappropriate it's
disgusting
it's disgusting calling out radical
islam
is not the same thing as suggesting that
that
ordinary everyday non-radical muslims
innocent people ought to be killed
that's absurdity at its highest level
and when people point out i did a video
a while back and which i just all the
video was was me citing polls
of muslims from around the globe in
different countries and talking about
the level of radicalism
in those various countries and people
say well this is islamophobic no those
are poll numbers
okay i talked about all of this at
university of pittsburgh not four months
ago
and i talked about the various
anti-semitic threats around the globe
and i talked about muslim anti-semitism
i point i talked about radical islam and
i pointed out that westernized muslims
are significantly less radical
and nearly non-radical in orientation as
opposed to
muslims who are living in for example
afghanistan
okay so this is not a matter of you
criticize
radical islam and therefore you're okay
with the murder of muslims in christ
church
what kind of insanity is this and again
we only apply this logic
on the level of the media when it is
convenient to a narrative that the west
is radically anti-islamic which again if
you've seen the response of the west to
this terrorist attack
i'm i'm failing to see it honestly i'm
failing to see it where are the people
who are out there defending it where are
the people who are saying we should
ignore the actual terrorist attack
where is that happening you know the
fact is
that inside the islamic world inside
countries that are governed by islam
they're muslim terrorists who are
killing thousands and thousands and
thousands of people
every single year to no generalized
public outcry
the reason there's outcry in the west is
because this does not meet the west's
values
everybody in the west knows this and
when we look
at people like this white supremacist
piece of garbage citing the west as a
rationale for his actions
we look at him we say you are a
disgusting human being and your ideology
is disgusting
the west is unified against this sort of
stuff and attempting to
draw lines in order to make political
hay
is really pretty vile stuff
now the easy in for a lot of folks on
the left
is of course attacking president trump
and that's because president trump
is a is a claude who says cloddish
things but if you're going to blame
president trump for the shooting in
christchurch i don't know how you get
there
i really don't know how you get there
unless you are also gonna blame bernie
sanders for the congressional baseball
shooting
you're gonna have to explain how
president trump called for violence
against people who go to mosque
because bernie sanders used radical
language against everybody who doesn't
agree with him on economics or climate
change we don't blame him for the
congressional baseball shooting does
that mean that his language is
appropriate no doesn't mean that
president trump's language
is appropriate no it doesn't but trying
to link him to white supremacism
and shooting attacks in new zealand is
really pretty gross and not only is it
gross
it's exactly what the shooter wanted so
i said last week that we shouldn't
discuss the manifesto we shouldn't go
out of our way to talk about the
the disgusting ideas in this killer's
manifesto and i meant that because
that's what he wanted what he wanted
was for his ideas to get out there i was
perfectly fine
and and more than fine i thought it was
important to label this a white
supremacist terror attack on muslims
i was very clear about this last week
but i didn't think that it was necessary
to go into the details
of his manifesto specifically because he
says in the manifesto that he wants to
divide americans from each other he
wants to divide people in the west
against each other and so he was using
his manifesto to do this
and the media were complicit in that
they decided they were going to jump on
this too and they were going to cite a
line in which he said that he admired
president trump
and they were going to use that as a way
to suggest that everyone who supports
president trump as well as president
trump himself
is somehow responsible for what just
happened in christchurch
here's an entire montage of people in
the media racing to blame president
trump
for an action he had nothing to do with
the shooter according to these
reports specifically invoked our
president
as an inspiration there's an intolerance
that's being
spread in this country in this world and
it comes from the political
dialogue let's be clear it comes from
political leaders words have
consequences
like saying we have an invasion or a
border the language he uses
in this manifesto is all about invaders
it's also language that president trump
used in a campaign ad before the midterm
election
you have a president who when he was a
candidate talked about
banning muslims from entering this this
country so this is a president
um who has given plenty of rhetorical
ammunition
i think to terrorists like this okay a
couple of things one you'll notice that
a bunch of these media
figures and political figures like bill
de blasio are out there citing president
trump's calling
the southern border an invasion as a
rationale for all of this
this wasn't an attack on illegal
immigrants number one number two i can
disagree with the president on his use
of the word invasion i don't think this
is an invasion i have forcefully spoken
out against that sort of language
but to link the president's border
policy with the shooting of muslims in
new zealand
forgive me if that seems like a bit of a
stretch now in a second we'll get to
president trump's rhetoric itself the
quote unquote muslim ban
and all the rest first let's talk about
bravo company manufacturing when the
founders crafted the constitution the
first thing they did was to make sacred
the rights of the individual to share
their ideas without limitation by the
government
the second right they enumerated was the
right of the population to protect that
speech and their own persons with force
you know how strongly i believe in these
principles
i'm a gun owner owning a rifle is an
awesome responsibility building rifles
is no different bravo company
manufacturing was started in a garage by
a marine veteran more than two decades
ago to build a professional-grade
product that meets combat standards
bcm believes the same level of
protection should be provided to every
american
regardless of whether they are a private
citizen or a professional bcm is not a
sporting arms company they design
engineer and manufacture life-saving
equipment they assume every rifle
leaving their shop will be used in a
life or death situation
by a responsible citizen law enforcement
officer or a soldier overseas
every component of a bcm rifle is
hand-assembled and tested by americans
to a life-saving standard to learn more
about bravo company manufacturing head
on over to bravocompanymfg.com that's
where you can discover more about their
products
special offers and upcoming news that is
bravocompanymfg.com if you need more
convincing
check out videos about them at
youtube.com bravo company usa
that is bravo company usa
bravocompanymfg.com youtube.com
bravo company usa so as you see the
media are attempting to
broaden the narrative so it starts at
the very outer edge with chelsea clinton
is responsible for christchurch because
she said mean things about ilhan omar
who's an anti-semite
and then it was moved into everybody who
has ever said anything about radical
islam is responsible
for what happened in christ church and
now it's president trump is personally
responsible
for what happened in christchurch
because of his language about
invaders because of his language about
the invasion of the country
don lemon on cnn was trying to say this
he was saying that the new zealand
terrorists looked up to trump and
therefore this is president trump's
fault
the suspect in the murders of at least
49 people at two mosques in new zealand
posted a manifesto online before
staging his rampage it's a white
nationalist greed
filled with hateful messages against
immigrants minorities and muslims
there's a reason why the shooter in his
manifesto
says that donald trump is a renewed
symbol of white identity who shares a
common purpose
what could be the common purpose that
the president united states of america
donald trump
who says i think islam hates us and
calls mexicans rapists and criminals
could have with the white nationalist
shooter who shot and killed 49 people i
think it's fairly
there's a couple of things that are
right and there there's there's don
lemon it's totally obvious what the
connection would be okay a couple of
things one
is president trump's language good on
this stuff no has it been good on this
stuff no i condemned it when he said it
way back in 2015 when he was talking
about
muslim when he was talking about a
full-on muslim ban we said it's time to
ban muslims from the country i said that
is stupid and wrong by the way his
actual practical ban
is not a muslim ban only five of the
seven countries on the travel ban
are muslim and they are the same seven
countries named by president obama so
that so the actual policy implemented
is not reflective of the language was
the language good no the language was
never good
okay but that's not the same thing as
blaming him for the shooting in christ
church
i don't remember again anyone in the
media saying you know whose name was on
the congressional baseball shooter's
lips bernie sanders
why because it didn't match the
narrative and we can condemn language
and we should condemn bad language but
trying to blame bad language for people
shooting each other in christ church
shooting each other a white supremacist
shooting people in christchurch
is is a real attempt to tear apart
our civilization it really is we should
be condemning bad ideologies
we should be actively fighting those bad
ideologies but that is not the same
thing as blaming president trump
for an event he did not have anything to
do with over in new zealand and of
course the the goal here is to proclaim
that everyone who then supports
president trump
is also a white nationalist now let's be
clear about this president trump has of
course
condemned what happened in christchurch
here's what president trump had to say
about it when it happened
i think it's a horrible event it's a
horrible thing i saw it early in the
morning when
i looked at what was happening in new
zealand i just spoke as you know to the
prime minister
i think it's a horrible disgraceful
thing and a horrible act
okay obviously president trump is not
big in favor of of all this but
with that said should the president give
some sort of address on the nature of
radical islam versus regular
islam should he give an address on why
muslims are full-fledged citizens of the
west
sure i don't see why not i mean the
guy's got time obviously he's tweeting
like crazy
i think that that would be a good thing
for the president of the united states
to do but make no mistake
the media's goal here is not to actively
tamp down the aspirations of the white
supremacists they are parroting his
claims
so that they can use them for
politically divisive purposes
they're doing exactly what the white
supremacist wanted them to do
he says so in the manifesto itself
it was enough to simply call out and say
listen white supremacism is evil
this person was evil and white
supremacism should be called out
wherever it's seen
but to try and turn it into a baton to
wield against people who are critical of
radical islam or ilhan omar
or people who support president trump
okay that's that's obviously done
in bad faith and and that is pretty
terrible stuff
it really is okay let's talk about 2020
so
there's an amazing disconnect between
what happens in the political
commentaries and what happens in the
real world
beta o'rourke raised in his first day in
the race in his very first day in the
race beto o'rourke raised
i kid you not 6.1 million dollars yeah i
think that calls for some better music
[Music]
[Applause]
that's right all right so beta o'rourke
raised 6.136 million dollars in online
donations
from all 50 states on his very first day
that is the number
one total it tops the 5.9 million one
day haul for senator bernie sanders
the other closest 2020 democratic
candidate senator kamala harris at 1.5
million dollars now that gives the lie
to the suggestion that he had not raised
a lot of money
this was the suggestion made last week
when o'rourke was asked specifically
about it and he sort of deferred he said
i'm not going to talk about that
now the media have turned on beto beto
has issued about 37 apologies
in his first 48 hours campaigning for
example
beto said in one of his appearances that
his wife did most of the raising of
their kids
which seems to me a compliment to his
wife not
a not an attempt to degrade his wife
nonetheless crazy people went went nuts
over this how dare beto say that his
wife did most of the raising of his
children
just absurd so beto apologized for that
so here's beto doing that
it's absolutely valid criticism and
it's constructive criticism it has
already made me
a better candidate not only will i not
say that
again um but but i'll be much more
thoughtful
going forward in in the way that um i
talk about our marriage and in my
hand-handed attempt
to try to highlight the fact that amy
has
the lion's share of the burden in our
family that she actually works
um but is the primary parent in our
family especially when i served in
congress especially when i was on
the campaign trail should have also been
a moment for me to
uh acknowledge that that is far too
often the case
okay so there's beto apologizing if you
don't if you can't get enough of
apologizing i have some more for you so
here's beto apologizing for his
failure to acknowledge his own white
privilege so this will be the beta or
work apology tour
as i've shared with with others and
certainly became a topic of conversation
in the senate campaign
i have been arrested twice in my life
one for attempted criminal trespass and
another uh more graver offense of
driving
while intoxicated those mistakes
didn't end up defining me or narrowing
my options in life and it's not because
i'm a great person
i'm a genius or i figured anything out a
lot of it has to do with the fact that
i'm
a white man uh that i have parents who
had the cash to post bail
at the time a lot of people
don't have that okay so there's beto
apologizing for being a white male so
that's very exciting for him as well
now the media have been jumping on this
well look at all of beto's gaffes so
many gaffes here is the problem they
already let bato
out of the cage okay beto is out of the
cage you spent two years building him up
as a senate candidate
against ted cruz and now you want to
shove him back in the cage because you
don't want him to be the nominee
too late my friends you built it you
bought it
okay we'll get to more of that i will
prove this to you in just one second but
first you're going to have to go over to
dailywire.com and subscribe so for 9.99
a month you can get a subscription to
daily
wire also before i go further with the
subscription pitch let me know that my
new book the right side of history
details the crisis of purpose that is
happening right now in western
civilization
if you want to know how we got here how
we can get back pre-order today at
amazon
barnes and noble any major bookseller i
cannot wait to share it with you i'm
going to discuss it at length
on the show tomorrow we have a big event
happening at reagan library as well
tomorrow i know that it's been
pre-selling like crazy
and i hope that you buy a copy i really
think it's an important work
and i think that in a time when the west
itself is being seen increasingly as a
bad thing when people are attacking the
west or when
people are deliberately misinterpreting
the west to mean
racial tribal polarization it's
important to know what the west was
originally supposed to be about how it
has broadened over time and how it has
become better
over time and how it has made the world
a better place go check it out the right
side of history that is available right
now at any of your book sellers also you
can check out if you want to sign copy
and go get one at
premierecollectables.com
ben shapiro we're doing a live book
signing tomorrow and if you buy a signed
copy of the book then we may answer your
question actually you don't have to be a
subscriber for that but
you should subscribe why should you
subscribe well for 9.99 a month or 99
a year not only do you get this podcast
live on video like the entire thing
you also get two hours more of me every
single day
on demand commercial free i mean that's
a lot that we are putting out there
for you and you get to ask questions and
you get to have if you spend for the
annual subscription you actually get
this the very greatest in beverage
vessels the leftist tiers hot or cold
tumbler
you can go check that out right now it's
pretty awesome you will enjoy it so go
check out all of those wonderful things
subscribe over at youtube and itunes
when you subscribe by the way you also
get our sunday special early you get it
on saturdays which means you could have
seen me with dr phil
on saturday as opposed to waiting to
just hear it in the audio
on sunday all sorts of great stuff
coming up
and i can't wait to share it with you so
go check it out right now youtube itunes
leave us a review we always appreciate
it we are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
so there's an attempt to shove beta
o'rourke back into the box because beta
o'rourke is of course a privileged white
male i pointed this out last week that
there were a couple of rich lines of
attack on beto o'rourke
now i underestimated his popularity
because i thought come on really
like this guy him i
sort of feel like michael bluth in in
arrested development looking at his
son's girlfriend
her i it's better really
him huh okay i guess
but here's the funny thing about this
the media who are now attempting to
paint beta o'rourke as a child of
privilege who doesn't actually have any
positions on the issues
they made him so you will recall all the
way back to 2016. i know you're older
than
than four years old so you'll remember
all the way back to 2016 when the media
did the exact same thing with with
president trump hilariously enough
against ted cruz
they figured okay we'll build up
president trump we'll spend a billion
dollars in free media coverage
on donald trump because dude's a joke
and people will figure it out
and eventually they'll decide that
they're not interested in him but first
we can use him to get past some of the
more serious republican candidates
and then by the time they tried to push
him back in the corner they couldn't
well nobody puts beto in a corner nobody
puts beto in a corner
okay reuters this is the best evidence
ever so reuters is now coming out with
the story about how beta o'rourke when
he was a teenager
was into hacking well there's a story
from reuters in which they reveal that
they had all this information
years ago quote reuters reporter joseph
men
exclusively revealed on friday that
democratic presidential candidate beta
o'rourke belongs to one of the
best-known groups of computer hackers
as a teenager within minutes his special
report was the most popular story on
reuters.com here
and was picked up by other news outlets
but the origin of the story
goes back more than two years members of
the group which calls itself cult of the
dead cow
protected o'rourke's secret for decades
reluctant to compromise
the former texas congressman's political
career after more than a year of
reporting men persuaded o'rourke to talk
on the record
in an interview in late 2017 o'rourke
acknowledged he was a member of the
group
on the understanding that the
information would not be made public
until
after his senate race against ted cruz
in november 2018
what in the actual so let me get this
straight a reuters reporter
said here is some newsworthy information
i will bury it until after your election
with ted cruz
and that's what the media was doing with
beta all along they were building him up
beto is indeed a lightweight
one of president trump's favorite terms
beta o'rourke has no original thoughts
better o'rourke is not
a shining example of deep thought
honestly if you want somebody who is
capable
of intelligent thought on the democratic
side side of the aisle it seems to me
the most intelligent candidate on the
democratic side of the aisle is that
mayor of south bend pete butterscheis
pete butter gig buddha okay that guy
actually seems kind of smart but
they don't work is not it but it's too
late the media built him up as a media
phenomenon
and now all of the people like jake
gyllenhaal who were wearing beto for
senate t-shirts back in 2018
are donating money to beto again the
media spent their attention
building this guy up to fight ted cruz
and then it is too late now
to shove him back in they can't do it
there's no way to get him back in there
now beto can be a gaff machine from here
to election day and that is what he is
doing
for example beto said yesterday like
offending everyone on every side of the
aisle that if you have an ar-15 you
should be able to keep your ar-15 but
you shouldn't be able to buy a new ar-15
which makes no sense to anyone
infiscated in either gun confiscation or
protection of second amendment rights
but here is beto making that claim
yesterday
we allow people in this country to buy
weapons
that were designed engineered and sold
to the united states military for the
express purpose of killing people
as effectively as possible in as great a
number
as possible now if you own an ar-15
keep it continue to use it responsibly
and safely i just don't think that we
need to sell
any more weapons of war into this public
okay so you know at the same time if you
so you can keep it it's a weapon of war
an evil evil weapon of war but also you
should keep it
this guy is the one you built up and now
you own it guys
now here's the truth beta or work will
do well among suburban women if you were
going to actually
if you were actually going to select
among the democratic candidates most
likely to be president trump beta would
probably be up high
on that list why because he does appeal
to suburban women he's got this kind of
softer feel to him
he's not quite as hard-edged as a bernie
sanders he's not an open socialist
the same way still
the the twitter verse is not reality
once again twitter
online world not reality and beto proved
that with his fundraising numbers for
sure now the gop
i don't know who's running these social
media accounts over the gop but all i
can say
is that it is ridiculous okay like what
are you doing
why would you do such a thing so on same
so in honor of st
patrick's day the gop decided to indulge
in a little bit of
making fun of the irish which is just a
genius tactic
very very smart stuff so here is what
the gop tweeted they tweeted out a
picture
of drunk beto from back when he had his
dui in the 90s
and he's got a he's got an irish
leprechaun hat and a four leaf clover
on his head or three leaf clover on his
head it says underneath please drink
responsibly
and then they tweeted out on this saint
patty's day a special message from noted
irishman
robert francis o'rourke what are you
even doing
what is wrong with you people like
legitimately this is stupid politics
i know there are a bunch of people who
love memes and so they're ah
i understand you think it's funny all
right
you know what else is not really funny
the fact there are lots of irish people
in the united states who may not be
pleased
with the notion that they are all drunk
lout
and the beta o'rourke is representative
of them on st patrick's day
just just absurd just absurd so
everybody being incompetent at their
jobs well done all around okay meanwhile
the other democratic candidates are
preparing their own runs
some successfully some less successfully
joe biden sort of let it slip
over the weekend that he was prep that
he was going to run
and here's the problem with joe biden
his best day will be his first day let's
get some joe biden music
oh yeah that's going to be joe biden's
run because he's going to be tripping
over that ottoman
every five seconds he's a he's a giraffe
on roller skates is joe biden
and so joe biden quasi launched his
campaign by accident
he said that he had the most progressive
record of anyone running
and then immediately switch oh i'm not
running yet yeah we all know do just do
it already just pull the trigger
enough i know i get criticized
i'm told i get criticized by the new
left i have the most progressive record
of anybody running for the united
if anybody who would run
i didn't mean
with anybody who would run okay now i
will note here he's obviously at a
dinner
so you can't take into account the
population of dinners as sort of the
base
of of the people who are going to vote
for that guy but there's a shot of the
crowd everyone is between the age of 70
and death
at the joe biden really beto however has
a bunch of
20-somethings who are out there dancing
dancing in the moonlight
so not good news for joe biden beto may
have stolen his thunder
meanwhile cory booker is attempting to
go as radical as possible in an attempt
to fend off kamala harris
it's basically like watching the hunger
games this this
version of the democratic primary
they're one million candidates and only
one will survive
let's get some spartacus music
there he is uh spartacus cory booker
what a wonderful dude
so cory booker he came out over the
weekend and he was trying to prove his
again progressive bonafides that he is a
fighter
and the thing about cory booker being a
fighter is that cory booker
is constantly endlessly manipulative and
so whenever he says something you can
feel the gear is turning well over the
weekend
he explained that it was not just enough
not to be a bigot you have to be an
anti-bigot
it's not just enough to say i'm not
racist you have to be an anti-racist
what the hell does this mean oh talk
about it corey it's not enough to say
i'm not a bigot you must be an
anti-bigot you must be an
anti-racial
now i have no problem with the general
idea that it's not enough to
to not be racist you actually have to
fight racism i just have a feeling that
what cory booker means by that is you
have to reflect my policy preferences or
i will call you a bigot
i will say that you might not be racist
but you forward the aspirations of
racists
and that's where that is going in pretty
shorter booker has no path i'm not sure
even why he's running
there's nothing happening for cory
booker in this race speaking of people
for whom nothing is happening in this
race
amy klobuchar also on the pandering
train and she's bought herself a panda
bear
so amy we we have some fargo music for
amy klobuchar from the frozen north
so she too is attempting to now pander
she understands there's an
intersectional lane
of the democratic primaries and that she
has no chance within it that's not going
to stop her from talking about
reparations so we have
half the democratic field now embracing
slavery reparations
in the year 2019 slavery was officially
ended in the united states in 1865
not a single democrat who backs slavery
reparations can explain what the hell it
is
other than it's a bunch of big
government programs i was already
proposing
just called slavery reparations here amy
klobuchar does the same thing
before apparently beating one of her
interns to death with the chair i
believe we have to invest in those
communities
that have been so hurt by racism it
doesn't have to be a direct
pay for each person but what we can do
is invest in those communities
acknowledge what's happened
and that means a better education that
means looking at for our whole economy
community college one year degrees
minimum wage
child care making sure that we have that
shared dream of opportunity for all
americans
okay so there she is pandering is it
going to do her anything good no amy
klobuchar is in the last year of
democratic candidates she's too moderate
she's too sane and also everything she
does to pander just makes her look less
authentic
speaking of which the least authentic
candidate of all time kirsten gillibrand
has launched her campaign to the great
excitement of dozens
dozens of people across the united
states desperately awaiting kirsten
gillibrand's
run let's get some kirsten jillibrand
music what do you mean
no one knows
[Music]
she's she's all she's all over the place
she's taking every position on every
issue and she is utterly again utterly
inauthentic so here was some of kirsten
gillibrand this 2020 launch video
watched by as i say her immediate family
plus her paid staff
our anthem calls america the home of the
brave
but we don't realize that the lyrics
first pose it as a question
oh say does that star-spangled banner
yet wave
over the land of the free and the home
of the brave
it asks will brave win well it hasn't
always
and it isn't right now we need a leader
who makes
big bold brave choices someone who isn't
afraid of progress
that's why i'm running for president and
it's why i'm asking
you for your support will brave win will
brave win will brave win um
we'll break the win
let's answer for ours okay yeah that's
going nowhere that is that is a
that is a rocket blowing up on launch oh
my goodness
yeah first of all if you are if you are
having to quote the lyrics to the
star-spangled banner in your opening
video
my favorite is is these candidates who
legitimately can't draw a crowd now what
you'll notice about
kamala harris's launch video or bernie
sanders's launch video
is that they always have a big crowd
right people who actually cheer for them
kirsten gillibrand like her alone in a
telephone booth
trying to this is my my support base
sure we started small
but soon soon a full hundred people
might
be with me at some point kirsten
gillibrand i mean speaking of
flip-flopping on positions
over the weekend she was talking about
the nra why because of christchurch new
zealand which it turns out new zealand
not in the united states here's kirsten
gillibrand however
talking about how we need to call out
the nra in the united states it's just
unbelievable that this president just
continues to put fuel on the fire of
hatred and bigotry
it's not who we are in our best moments
as a nation and it's not who we should
be in the future
so i i think it's outrageous and so
i my heart goes out to the victims it is
it is a
horrible shooting and another crisis
in the in the world um but we need a
president who's actually going to do the
right things and stand up to the nra
and stand up against hate i'm old enough
to remember when kirsten gillibrand got
an a rating from the nra
wasn't that funny yeah kirsten
gillibrand that campaign going nowhere
okay time for some stuff i like and then
we'll do some stuff
that i hate so a couple so a thing that
i like today there's a very good book
about israel's history i'm very often
asked about
what's a good book to read about the
israeli-palestinian conflict
that conflict obviously in the news
again because there was another
terrorist attack over the weekend in
which a 47 year old father of 12 was
murdered by a palestinian terrorist
and the hamas government in the gaza
strip which has been summarily shooting
its own citizens
decided that they would hand out candies
upon the death of innocent israelis
we ignore that we're not supposed to pay
attention to that that's that's very
important to ignore
there's a good book about all of this
called reclaiming israel's history by
david bragg
roots rights and the struggle for peace
it is it is a nuanced look at israel's
history acknowledging
where israel has failed and pointing out
where israel has succeeded the book is
is quite good it's an easy read it's
only about 250 pages maybe
so go check that out right now
reclaiming israel's history by david
bragg speaking of which
you know this goes under things i hate
obviously but it is amazing to watch as
the western media completely ignore
hamas shooting its own citizens in the
streets
in the gaza strip they're legitimately
doing this like people are finally
finally protesting in the gaza strip
against the egregious misrule of hamas
years ago i tweeted
about israelis loving to build and arabs
loving to live in crap and
and bomb things and i was specifically
talking as i said in that thread you can
go read it
as i was specifically talking about the
leadership of hamas
specifically talking about the
leadership of the palestinian authority
that would rather its own citizens live
in sewage than actually pay to better
the lives
of those citizens i was specifically
talking about that that remains true
okay the leadership in hamas the
leadership in the palestinian authority
would rather line their own pockets and
build terror tunnels than take care of
their citizens and now they're shooting
their own citizens in the gaza strip
now here's what that looked like
any media coverage of this guys any
media coverage have come off shooting
its own citizens in the gaza strip
nope none at all nope it's all israel
israel is the problem okay time for some
things that i hate
okay so a couple of quick things that i
hate so there is a senator in australia
and this senator in australia is indeed
a basket of dung
he's a bad guy okay so this this
australian far-right senator named
frazier anning put out an egregious
statement in the aftermath of the christ
church killing talking about how it was
muslim immigration to new zealand that
had caused it which is just an absurdity
and a moral blot and all the rest uh
here is
this so this guy was speaking to the
media and he's garbage but
a person behind him the 17 year old hits
him with an egg
and here's what happens next when people
are getting
attacked in their own
okay and then his guys take down the kid
now uh
people have gone crazy on the politician
for this now should go crazy on the
politician for his views his views are
garbage
but if you're gonna look crazy on a guy
for getting hit in the head with an egg
and then turning around and slapping the
guy you hit him with an egg
i'm not with you there i don't think you
should punch nazis i don't think you
should slap eggs on the heads of people
with whom you disagree
i think that in a civilized society we
have discussions and debates about this
stuff
and that violence in response to
viewpoint is a terrible idea this is a
bad idea
so you know people who are all over the
guy for be all over the guy for his
views don't be all over the guy for
turning around and slapping the kid who
hit him in the head with an egg
the kid got what he deserved for
slapping the guy in the head with an egg
now
except for what happened afterward
apparently what happened afterward is
that this guy's
goons then beat the kid up that of
course is inappropriate
and absurd so many things can be true at
once one
goons once the guy is subdued don't beat
the crap out of him two don't
slap your political opponents in the
head with eggs three if you act in
self-defense even if you have bad views
that is still called self-defense all of
these things can be true at once
but everything is gross okay final thing
that i hate today so jk rowling has now
decided it is time to make her books
retroactively intersectional
so that's exciting nowhere in her books
does she talk about dumbledore being gay
but you remember a few years ago she
suggested that dumbledore was gay now
this is not coming from a harry potter
partisan i'm actually not a huge fan of
the harry potter books i think that they
are
overwrought i think they are over long
they're just not i'm just not a big fan
but she is now talking in her she's now
talking
for the special features for the
upcoming fantastic beats the crimes of
grindelwald blue
blu-ray she reveals that there was a
sexual dimension between albus
dumbledore and gellert grindelwald
like this is a thing now so she's now
going to she didn't write it in the
books and it's not in the movies
but she's going to actively we're now
going to learn that hermione
was black she just didn't know it nobody
knew it that hermione was black
because obviously it turns out that that
hogwarts was not intersectional
enough dobby was transgender it's very
exciting to learn all these things
retroactively the fact that the media
allowed jk rowling to get away with this
nonsense is really astonishing
doesn't it demonstrate how exploitative
sjw nonsense is
meaning that all she has to do is throw
out there that these characters who she
never characterized in this way
are actually all these things the sjw
left wants them to be
and then they're like cheer and then
they're cheering
shouldn't they have criticized her at
the time for not making the characters
openly that way
i mean if you want a transformative
world wouldn't you want jk but
she's getting off easy by simply not
writing any of that stuff so that i can
buy
these books for my eight-year-old and
then later she'll tell us that
dumbledore was gay
and get all the sjw plotted it's pretty
pretty astonishing
i am looking forward to learning about
the sexual peccadilloes that were
happening
in general tolkien's middle earth i need
to know about sauron's sex life
i think it's deeply important i need to
know if hobbiton
was was a seamy bed
of vile undertakings i need to know
about all of these things
it's very very important so i look
forward to hearing from the tolkien
estate what
what in and stupid world we live in okay
we will be back here a little bit later
this afternoon with two more hours also
make sure that you go pre-order my book
because
you don't want to be one of the unlucky
people who wants to buy the book when it
runs out of stock
it's the right side of history go check
it out at any bookstore
it comes out tomorrow or you can buy an
autographed copy of
premierecollectables.com
ben shapiro that comes along with the
benefit of maybe being able to ask me a
question in tomorrow's live book signing
so go check that out
right now we'll see you a little bit
later today or we'll be here tomorrow
with you this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
this is the ben shapiro show executive
producer jeremy boring
senior producer jonathan hay our
supervising producer is mathis glover
and our technical producer is austin
stevens
edited by adam syvitz audio is mixed by
mike caromina hair and makeup is by
jessua olvera production assistant nick
sheehan the ben shapiro show is a daily
wire production
copyright daily wire 2019